pauli ein alkoholiker fast wäre es
passiert warum das erzählt er jetzt im
interview und wie youtube sein leben
verändert hat und was mich interessieren
würde die hat youtube euer leben
verändert post in den kommentaren und
ansonsten bis dann bleibt ja
was
war damals leicht wie lange die lage ist
ziemlich durch den wind als er
wortwörtlich care und sagen und das
wetter draußen ist nicht unbedingt das
beste er ist von parteien besser aber
jetzt ich hoffe das wird ja wieder
richtig noch nicht
ist dass ich sag mal mag das wetter hier
in hamburg oder hast du es manchmal das
kann ich hier nicht um die zahlen also
manchmal hast dich jetzt manchmal mag
ich es aber ich bin ziemlich da immer
auf die stadt selbst also ich liebe
hamburg selbst das wetter daran kann man
sich gewöhnen ja ja also manchmal
geschlecht ist auch gar nicht so
schlecht auch wenn das jetzt ein
bisschen komisch kriegt okay was wieso
ist manchmal schlechtes wetter nicht
schlecht wenn man depressionen hat oder
so damit man mehr weiter oder beratung
das heißt nur ausreden hamburg ins gute
licht zu rücken es ist ja auch schön
also es ist ja sehr luft ist ja was
tolles aber eben manchmal wenn es dann
kalt ist und noch windig ist es ja sehr
wichtig aber nicht also eine hamburg
über frieden du kommst aber ausnahmen
land wo es vor allem im sommer
wahrscheinlich brütend warm war auf
jeden fall und entweder einfach nur
arschkalt alte schlager aus kasachstan
komme ich mir aus je vielfalt kennt ich
weiß es nicht und es war ein sehr
schönes land man hat sich gegenseitig
unterstützt und man hat nicht viel also
wir lebten wirklichen ärmlichen
verhältnissen könnte man sagen also wir
hatten nicht mit der heizung ich durfte
ja wir hatten keine heizung also wir
wohnen in einer ärmlichen wohnung und
ich durfte im winter dann wirklich mit
sondern dicken jacke mit zwei decken im
bett schlafen und das war nicht
unbedingt schön also deswegen bin ich
ganz gut dass wir in deutschland sind
weil hier die verhältnisse und generell
das lebens verhältnis viel besser ist
als in karlstadt deswegen verstehe ich
auch die leute nicht die hier geboren
sind und sagen nur deutscher der scheiße
und kann ich mir auch nicht
nachvollziehen weil deutschland hat
natürlich auch seine macken aber
trotzdem gefällt es mir ziemlich gut
aber nochmal zu wenig muss wie der
heizung man verstehen
ich schätze mal da sind so - 20 -30 grad
ja wir sind im winter wie geht ich meine
da geht man ja nicht mal wasser also ich
meine wie geht das ohne halt so ja ich
kann es nicht genau sagen also ist es
auf jeden fall ziemlich lange her also
habe ich war da sechs jahre als
also ich war gerade mal sechs jahre nach
deutschland gezogen bringen das sind so
einige erinnerungen fragt momente die
ich dann plötzlich ohne heizung schlafen
durfte und dass ich meine oma besuchen
kam und zu essen solche sachen die mir
immer wieder ein und alles kann ich mich
nicht erinnern aber naja es war auf
jeden fall ein schönes zeit das weiß ich
ok also kalt arm aber ziemlich schön
sind die kultur war auch ziemlich geil
ja man hat sich gegenseitig unterstützt
und
die waren alle super nett und man hat
sich mal begrüßt auch wenn man hier die
persönlich kannte das ist hier ja wohl
hier gibt es natürlich auch viele mehr
einwohner als dem hier ist meine
heimatstadt und es war auch ziemlich
familiär könnte man sagen es war auf
jeden fall cool bist du denn oder traust
du dir manchmal nach wenn du sagst es
war sehr schön oder da haben sie die
leute gegenseitig geholfen
nicht unbedingt also wie gesagt lebten
wir ein ziemlich ärmlichen verhältnissen
deswegen bin ich eigentlich ziemlich
dankbar ging weil man den eltern dass
wir oder dass sie die idee hatten nach
deutschland zu ziehen und ich glaube ich
dort geblieben wäre wäre ich heute
jemand der jeden tag alkohol trinken
würde und mich ständig besorgt besoffen
würde die mann der mit einer glatze
rumrennen würde und andere verprügeln
würde also ich glaube in der gegend
werde ich ganz anders geworden als dass
ich mich halt heute bin willst du damit
oder bist du happy damit wie du geworden
bist durch die veränderten umstände ich
eigentlich ziemlich happy gebäude also
ich akzeptiere mich so wie ich bin nicht
verstehe mich nicht und ich habe auch
keinen grund mich zu verstellen und ja
ich bin happy hat so was wie video
machen dabei geholfen so eine
selbstsicherheit zu bekommen auf jeden
fall also ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
als ich damals noch klein war war ich
total schüchtern also ich war das total
gegen das totale gegenteil als heute
aber heute können sich wirklich jeden
ansprechen und die schüchternheit es
einfach mal weg also zumindest wenn ich
damals klar gibt es so einige
situationen wo ich noch ziemlich
schüchtern bin aber mittlerweile hat
sich das wirklich gelegt und ich kann
wirklich mit ihm reden und wenn leute
mich zum beispiel auf der straße
erkennen sagen hey wie kann ich mit dem
ich ganz normal unterhalten als wenn das
ein kumpels von mir und ich bin wirklich
froh und das war vorher nicht so das war
vorher gar nicht so also ich war daher
könnte man sagen der außenseite früher
uns mittlerweile hat sich das doch ein
bisschen gehabt durch die videos machen
und so ich habe ja erst letztens gemacht
und dadurch dass wir ihn tag zur kamera
gesprochen habe und die leute ran was
auch wirklich gut die haben gesagt hey
dann steht man also die ist so als die
es so da kann man wirklich gern zuhören
und ich mag deine stimme solche
kommentare die bauern einen aufgegeben
einem selbstvertrauen und ein selbst
selbst sicheres gefühl und mittlerweile
habe ich absolut nichts gegen 1 stimme
also früher habe ich meine stimme total
gehasst ja ich er hat man bestimmt total
gehabt und ich konnte mir gar nicht
selber zu hören also ich wollte um die
cluster werden habe ich meine folgen
gesehen und dachte ich mir ob man das
will doch niemand gucken uns aber auch
der ausdruck der ist mit dem essen
gewordene jahre also wenn du ganz viele
video das machst und vor der kamera
versucht sie ja nicht so deutlich wie
möglich auszusprechen dann wirst du auch
immer besseren und wenn du das herz
vergleich mit der schule hat sich das
dann auch auf ein reales leben ich sage
mal unter freunden
ausgewirkt bist du darauf vom
außenseiter zum in anführungszeichen
insider geworden also ich bin ich aber
nicht insider also meinem freundeskreis
gibt es jetzt niemanden der coole jemand
nicht cool ist also ja sind einfach
untereinander und akzeptieren uns
untereinander und aber ich bin ich muss
ganz ehrlich zugeben ich besuchte jemand
der gerne im mittelpunkt steht und das
war gar nicht so also früher war jemand
der gern im hintergrund steht der sich
von einem aus einem hatte heraushalten
wollte aber mittlerweile mag es mit
mittelpunkt zu stehen und ich genieße
das leben das heißt du hast so quasi mit
dem video machen eine schwelle zur
selbsteinschätzung überschritten das ist
das können wir wirklich zu sagen aber
ich bin auch nicht der einzige ich kenne
viele andere youtuber die waren früher
auch so und die haben wirklich ein
selbstsicheres gefühl und sind generell
auch haben mehr selbstvertrauen geworden
da hab ich dass die youtube videos
machen und es ist wirklich man merkt es
auch okay und die andere leute merken
dass wirklich auch also ich habe zum
beispiel freunde die ich seit jahren
kenne und ich finde auch dass ich mich
verändert habe aber nicht zum negativen
sollten positiven dadurch dass ich jetzt
mehr selbstvertrauen habe das würde ja
bedeuten youtube als therapie
von krankheiten ist jetzt wieder mal
gesagt gesagt dass eine krankhafte ich
habe youtube als
genau als hilfe zur reife genau oder alt
apps bestätigen ja das brauchen ja auch
viele menschen ja dass sie von anderen
hören wie sie sind oder was sie machen
oder wie sie klingen und so sollten so
eine selbstbestätigung das kann ein klub
wieder gebrochen um seinem
selbstwertgefühl ein bisschen auf trab
zu halten warum hast du es denn aber dir
nicht diese selbstbestätigung in der
realen welt holen können sondern hast
den umweg über video gemacht auf unter
schüchternheit ja also wenn ich wieder
machen bin ich ja quasi nur vor der
kamera und da kann ich mich vor der
kamera nicht blamieren und da kann ich
im nachhinein noch sagen okay das video
ist gut dass lade ich hoch und wenn ich
sage das ist nicht gut dann kann ich
jetzt mal wieder löschen also ich bin
nicht quasi unter druck gesetzt ich kann
sagen hey wenn das wetter gut ist kann
ich das hochland die leute finden das
gut dann hat man eine bestätigung aber
im echten leben musst du dich immer
beweisen muss sich beweisen und wenn
dann schüchtern bist ist das ganz schwer
das heißt das risiko ich glaube jeder
mal leben ist live das kann es nicht
ändern wenn du was gesagt das ist es
gesagt das risiko zu scheitern ist viel
viel größer als wir uns erstmal
aufzeichnet und egal dass es auch
millionen menschen sehen können aber das
risiko ist verringert dadurch dass man
es einfach im griff hat wie man sie
selber darstellt genau ungefähr so also
ist natürlich natürlich sollte man auch
versuchen bringt wieder so gehe ich aber
dass fertigung der game machen auch
versuchen sich zu beweisen dass ist das
war schon immer so und das wird auch
immer so bleiben und so aber youtube
kann trotzdem dennoch helfen also wenn
du wirklich wieder was machst du hast
ein gutes gefühl dabei und andere leute
finden das gut dann kann es wirklich
helfen auch im echten leben hätte ich
besser beweisen zu können aufgrund
dessen dass deine schüchternheit ein
bisschen weniger wird okay aber es gibt
ja ohne ende hater
com ist ich sag mal ist da nicht die
gefahr dass man auch wahnsinnig schnell
gemobbt wird ich sag mal beispiele wie
mörder money boy die natürlich ein
riesenerfolg dann auch haben aber
trotzdem die werden ja gemobbt ohne ende
aber auch ist aber wir hatten bei uns
man nutzer frage an coldmirror die wurde
auch gerätselt ohne ende sie sagt
allerdings jetzt erstens das war für
mich wahnsinnig wichtig ich habe eine
freundin fürs leben dadurch gefunden und
letztlich mal als starke persönlichkeit
aber trotzdem denke ich manchmal auch
ich selber das greift anja immer an dass
ein großes risiko oder ist es keine
chance also
ich würde das so betrachten wenn du
hunger hast dann ist es auch eine
bestätigung man sollte es auch als eine
form der bestätigung sehen wenn wenn
leider hat bzw hater dann weißt du genau
das was erreicht hast und im echten
leben die spricht nicht gar nicht
wirklich an weil ich ja zum beispiel von
den aussenseitern das sind ja wirklich
die größten deutschen youtube und als
mann ich weiß laut die mader hat es
glaube ich in irgendeinem video erwähnt
dass sie auf der straße nie wirklich
negativ angesprochen wurden und das
obwohl sie die größten deutschen
youtuber sind und im internet werden sie
ständig geld ohne ende von was ich wie
vielen leuten und ich habe dass ich habe
einfach das gefühl das sind so leute die
müssen ihre frust rauslassen ein youtube
und irgendein youtuber weil sie das
sonst nicht können an ihrem freund an
ihren eltern was trauen sie sich gar
nicht uns sondern nutzen sie quasi die
anonymität des internets und dann lassen
sie ihre post ein youtuber aus und das
ist das sollte man einfach nicht ernst
nehmen weil die das würden die sich im
echten leben gar nicht trauen zu sagen
das ist einfach so und deswegen nimmt
das auch gar nicht ernst anfang habe ich
das natürlich schon ernst genommen aber
mittlerweile nehme ich das gar nicht
mehr ernst also ich einfach blockieren
und löschen und das war's und aber das
ist nunmal man kann nicht sagen dass sie
hätte alle auf einmal kommen weil das
kommt ja mit dem erfolg kommen immer
mehr hält und man gewöhnt sich tragen ja
ich habe die 100000 abo grenze ich
glaube danach geht s richtig da ist
richtig was ja bei mir schon ab 20.000
abonnenten habe ich überhaupt kein held
wollte ich nur leute die immer darum
hoch gaben und die immer gesagt haben
hey du hast ein cooles video und dann
kam irgendwann erster hält und nicht
total genervt und dann kam noch ein
hater und dann wurde schon ein bisschen
gruselig aber habe ich mich total daran
gewöhnt und es ist überhaupt nicht
schlimm also ich nehme das nicht ernst
ich ziehe mein ding durch und ich denke
mir hält man ist auf youtube und das ist
einfach nur unterhaltung um die videos
gucken will dann guckt man sie halt wenn
man keinen bock drauf hat dann macht man
es eben nicht also aber so hat man nicht
so ernst nehmen aber gibt sich mal im
moment wenn dich ein manchmal trifft jan
hater kommentar der trifft er seine
schwache stelle man immer was ist dann
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen so hätte
kommt haben wie zum beispiel wenn leute
schreiben hätte bis total scheiße oder
du bist schwul oder was ich überhaupt
schwul ist kann er bereitet
das trifft mich überhaupt nicht was mich
eher trifft sind so wenn fans schreiben
du wirst mal schlechter oder so das will
ich dann wiederum ein bisschen aber das
kann man ja auch als konstruktive kritik
betrachten und dann beim nächsten mal
gucken was man besser machen kann was
ich jedoch nicht so ernst nehmen kann
weil leute schreiben zu spielen was
immer schlechter aber keine begründung
schreiben dann sehe ich das als hätte
kommentar also ich finde man sollte auch
begründen der heute eine konstruktive
also zu einer konstruktiven kritik
gehört ja auch begründungen und
wenn die dabei ist dann finde ich das
vollkommen ok und dann halte ich mich
noch dran das muss ich auch sagen wenn
da wirklich ein kommentar sagt das video
ist schlecht ausdehnen und den gründen
dann finde ich das super finde ich auch
nicht wann liebisch das dann muss ich
sagen da freue ich mich riesig darüber
nur wenn dies wenn sie ist einfach
irgendwas nehmen um die schlecht zu
machen sie wir gucken ja und ich weiß
wie es bei dir ist ich gucke dass ich
auch wenn ich fehler mache lasse ich die
gerne drin weil das gehört zur
authentizität dazu weil wenn du die
fehler nicht drin lässt dann ist es ja
irgendwann ist es wie fernsehen und
stefan schade und wenn die leute dann
genau das sind wiederum schüttelt dann
bin ich immer so und das dann aber nur
bisschen blöd weil
dann hatte ich das ja also bei mir ist
ein bisschen anders ich lasse meine
fehler nicht drin also ich schnell als
quasi ein jump kann also nur einige
ein bisschen perfekt rüber ernst weil
ich einfach so ein perfektionist bin
also manchmal brauche ich schon für drei
oder vier sätze immer neue steak ja
ehrlich das einfach perfekt rüber
bringen will aber dann wiederum bringe
ich auch outtakes rein damit die leute
sehen ich bin auch nicht perfekt das
muss ja auch mal sein und jetzt zum
beispiel habe ich mich auf ein paar mal
verplappert und soja ist absolut nicht
schlimm ich meine das ist menschlich
niemand kann perfekt reden ohne punkt
und komma doch gibt es war das nochmal
ja
ok kannst du die damals noch der name
sagt mir was das der hat der moderator
inzwischen ist er glaube ich nicht mehr
in amt und würden der hat lange lange
jahre die deutsche hitparade moderiert
ok und die wahl live und zum schluss hat
er gesagt wer mitgewirkt hat und zwar
also nicht als abschluss sondern hat das
gesagt und dass der wagen war die leute
die gerade mit der in der region
ich kann sich so schnell und der hat so
aber das und live und jeden tag ohne
schnitt plan sind ja damals das ist aber
wirklich geübt da frage ich mich wie
lange vor dem spiegel
wie ist das eigentlich bei dir was übung
ist das ein wichtiger punkt oder direkt
vor der kamera und machen sich über gar
nicht also direkt vor die kamera und
machen das ist bei mir der fall ich
schreibe immer so ein kleines skript uns
also ein kleines tool also schreibt
nicht genau wie das abgelaufen ist ich
habe mir nur ein paar stichpunkte könnte
man sagen und an die halte ich mich dann
und dass der rest den rest habe ich im
kopf und dann stelle ich mich vor die
kamera und dann fange ich an dann sage
ich mir okay der erste satz der war
nicht so gut da habe ich ein paar
versprecher drin und dann fange ich erst
mal an und dann kann es wirklich sein
dass ich mal wenn ich vor der kamera
stehen zwei bis drei stunden brauchen
und dann im video selbst dass nur drei
minuten ja ja das ist merken die leute
gar nicht es ist wirklich schwer okay
also quasi üben während der produktion
das kann man sagen okay okay wenn du
jetzt das ist ja etwas besonderes bei
den youtube an man wächst ja auf und
wächst quasi im beruf rein kannst du dir
das vorstellen also wenn du in die
zukunft liegt das ewig zu machen die ich
weiterhin zu entwickeln in etwas was wir
jetzt vielleicht noch nicht wissen oder
sagst du dir das ist jetzt eine
zeiterscheinung und in 20 jahren was
weiß ich werde steuerbeamter
comcom die youtuber zum steuergelder
ausgibt das ist gut das ist kein modell
ja das ist kommen die erstmalig sagen
ich wollte sagen markus rother gefallen
das macht was ich aus
ich setze mir jetzt keinen grundlegenden
ziele also ich setze ich ziehe mein
eigenes ding durch und dann schaue ich
einfach wie es wird und haben bisher bin
ich ein youtube machen also das gefällt
mir wirklich sehr und ich versuche mich
zu verbessern und wenn ich bei den
später was anderes mache aus youtube
dann will ich auf jeden fall ins
mediengeschäft schreiten weil er mein
ding ist also ich liebe das video schon
ein video das zuschneiden und ich liebe
es vor der kamera zu sein alles möglich
also alles was mit den medien zu tun hat
das liebe ich einfach aber dann muss ich
das auf das internet spezialisieren weil
ich mag einfach ich sag mal die
medienwelt das internet viel lieber als
die vom fernsehen also das schon mal
berührungspunkte sagt berührungspunkte
und noch nicht mit herrn nicht wirklich
aber du hast hat produziert wird was du
da sein aber ich habe einiges gesehen so
hinter den kulissen und es ist nicht
unbedingt mein ding also ich mag es
lieber wenn es wirklich wenn ich
wirklich machen kann was ich will oder
kamera und das ist auch mein ding weil
wenn ich mir vorstelle dass andere leute
für mich irgendwie schon ein und sollen
ist nicht das was ich mir
hundertprozentig vorstelle und wenn ich
wenn ich das machen kann was ich mir
hundertprozentig vorstellen dann will
ich das auch durchziehen und dann kann
ich sagen hey den leuten könnte das
gefallen weil ich bin der typ andere
leute wenn die videos machen die sagen
sich immer oder die überlegen sich immer
was könnt ihr den anderen leuten
gefallen aber ich denke gar nicht so ich
denke mir immer was könnte mir selber
gefallen wenn ich das video nicht kenne
also das was ich selber produzieren dann
würde ich das nicht kennen würde und zum
ersten mal auf youtube sehen würde würde
mir das gefallen würde ich darüber
lachen falls ja dann ziehe ich das durch
da weiß ich dann kann ich mir sagen dass
die anderen auch darüber lachen werden
und das ist glaube ich das was mich von
anderen leuten unterscheidet also ich
denke nicht darüber nach was die anderen
leute lustig finden kann sondern was ich
lustig finden könnte wenn ich das ich
kennen würde ok hast du geschwister ich
bin einzelkind was sagen deine eltern
meine eltern die finden das auf jeden
fall klar die sind gerade diesen stolz
auf die gucken sich auch meine videos an
auch wenn sie nicht alles verstehen aber
da sie nicht so gut deutsch kann ich zum
beispiel
aber die finden dass also die finden das
relativ professionell was sie sehen und
unterstützt mich auch da vollkommen die
erzählen auch von anderen ort also die
wirklich stolz auf mich dir erzählen
anderen leuten davon und mittlerweile
also wir sind ja vor ewigkeiten nach
deutschland gezogen gern mal sechs jahre
alt und die haben sich natürlich an die
verhältnisse in deutschland gewöhnt und
die kümmern sich auch schon darum dass
sie so ein bisschen mit der modernen
technik konfrontiert werden und die
fanden das vollkommen normal also dass
ich das mache die fanden das war cool
und klar am anfang war das natürlich
schwer niemand von uns konnte deutsch
mein vater nur um so ein bisschen
deutsch heute deutsche oper so muss man
sagen deine eltern sind keine rosen
sondern sind deutsche
mittlerweile ja also dass sie waren ja
auch volkswagen deutsche wann sie raus
neben meiner oma war deutsche roma war
deutsche gerne deutsche ja und meine
eltern sind russen so richtig gerissen
und in kasachstan das gehört ja damals
zur sowjetunion und deswegen auf grund
dessen leben da ja auch viele russen ja
wobei
aber wenn deine oma deutsche war dann
war doch wirklich an mütterlicher seite
väterlich väterlicher dann könnte man
sagen dass man versucht ja dass sie
gelten ja als russlanddeutsche das war
ja damals da ganz viele russlanddeutsche
hier wieder dürfen danach hat sie mit
mit dem zweiten weltkrieg zu tun da wo
man damals abgesprochen jeder
russlanddeutsche kann zurück nach
deutschland kommen und in dem zugesagt
jährigen gekommen dass da wurde da gar
nicht deutsch gesprochen oder wunden
ganz von der oma die hat ja vorhin
deutschland gelebt das weiß ich ja und
es danach karten gezogen aus eigenem
interesse und ist wohl hauptsächlich
russ gesprochen und meine romandie
konnte halt auch schon deutsche oder
auch nicht perfekt so und na ja
mittlerweile haben wir uns alles mal
gewöhnen meine eltern können auch
deutsch sprechen nur halt nicht so gut
auch mit akzent ja aber ich muss dazu
sagen als ich nach deutschland kam hatte
ich auch anfassen akzent aber den habe
ich mir einen anderen weg trainiert ihr
körper mit sechs jahren geht das noch
ich bin ob auch nie irgendwie ein akzent
also mit 67 bis nach köln gekommen und
irgendwie aus rüsselsheim ich war
irgendwie hab ich nicht angenommen ich
glaube in dem alter kann man das noch
sehr gut ab legen ja das kann man sagen
ja so auf jeden fall ich hatte anfangs
zum ganz leicht mehr zähne aber dadurch
dass ich in norddeutschland bin und
viele leute reden hier auch
hauptsächlich hochdeutsch
kam das über die jahre quasi von alleine
ein bisschen habe ich auch trainiert
also ich denke quasi schon gelacht die
sprechen dass man uns auf der sich nun
was kann ich dann besser machen weil ich
mir dann wieder hochdeutsch klingt so
intelligenz und uns und wendet werde ich
zum beispiel akzent räder ist ein gar
nicht so intelligent also ich hatte ein
bisschen angst vor ja noch ein kind das
ich so ein bisschen dumm rüberkommen
will ich damit mit einem russischen
akzent räder und nicht uns ja meine
klassenlehrerin damals wir auch nicht
unbedingt in der die hat immer gesagt ja
das sprechen so und so aus habe mich
wirklich angemeckert deswegen will ich
den russischen akzent und hast du nicht
schon ein bisschen kraft also würde mich
nicht wundern wenn ich ein bisschen
rechts ist gut das ist eine andere
geschichte ich will jetzt nicht rollen
oder flammen hier vor dem interview
vielleicht seht ihr das sehr aber die
kennt nicht bis dahin endlich mehr also
heute ist kennt sie mich eh nicht mehr
deswegen kann ich da so viel sagen wie
ich will über sie nein wenn ich mich
machen
aber mittlerweile würde ich schon
behaupten dass man deutsch relativ gut
ist und auf einem hohen niveau also
natürlich rede ich nicht so viel mit
fremdwörtern aber ich würde schon
geheuer und muss man auch nicht also
braucht man auch nicht ich bin jetzt
nicht unbedingt der meinung dass ich
jetzt total intellektuelle rüberkommen
muss in dem ich ganz viele fremdwörter
benutzten ist braucht er einfach nicht
ich hatte meine zeit meine zeit da
wollte ich das da habe ich wirklich so
dinge gegoogelt auf wikipedia was
bedeutet denn metaphysik oder was
bedeutet denn hier falls ich kationen
was ist da sind sondern habe ich die
wörter im alltäglichen gebrauch benutzt
okay war sie als intelligent über dazu
kommen aber das war völliger blödsinn
als erster wieder mache ich das nicht
mehr und ich würde schon behaupten dass
man deutsch ganz okay so ich würde dich
sagen also ich glaube wenn man so jung
nach in irgendein land kommt dann
spielt es überhaupt keine rolle mehr ja
klar aber man muss berücksichtigen man
redet ja trotzdem stehen sie mit seinen
eltern russisch also auch heute noch bis
heute rede ich mit meinen eltern nur
russisch und na ja zu dem zeitpunkt als
ich hierher gezogen bin hatte ich auch
nicht viele freunde also nur ein element
artig und deswegen habe ich auch da
überwiegend russisch gesprochen und erst
ab der ersten erst ab der ersten oder
zweiten klasse ranking das richtig los
willst du denn hast du dich da
ausgegrenzt gefühlt in der grundschule
noch oder den anfangszeiten ja auf jeden
fall also als ich meine klasse kam die
waren alles total gemein zu mir ich ganz
ehrlich sagen oder denkt jetzt so die
goldmanns milch honig im interview aus
die haben solche sachen gesagt die
chance und so was also das hat mir
überhaupt nicht gefallen und ich habe
mich auf jeden fall ausgesetzt gefühlt
aufgrund dessen auch dass ich nicht so
gut deutsch konnte und deswegen konnte
ich mich auch nicht mehr rechtfertigen
würde mich perfekt ausdrücken wie die
anderen leute und deswegen hatte ich das
nicht mal leicht
aufgrund dessen habe ich mich mit ein
paar tagen aus der parallelklasse
zusammengetan und so und wir haben dann
das quasi den spieß umgedreht oder so
was ich heute noch bereue aber naja das
ist die migrationspolitik dahinter also
es ist das integrationsproblem so
deswegen habe ich auch das video gemacht
auf meinem video kanal dass man sich
gegenseitig besser verstehen sollte und
dass man sich nicht immer so runter
machen sollte weil die ausländer sollen
aufhören scheiß deutsche zusagen und die
deutschen sollen aufhören die ausländer
auszugrenzen dann wäre das leben perfekt
das heißt nicht integration ist das
problem sondern das problem ist dass man
sich gegenseitig respektiert ja und die
vorurteile ja so dass man sich nicht
respektiert und die vorurteile dahinter
das finde ich auch sehr schade und das
ist bis heute auch nicht zu ändern ist
es besser geworden über die jahre das
habe ich auch wirklich gemerkt und das
will ich auch gut ich
finde ich auch sehr lobenswert und ich
hoffe das wird auch mit der zeit
wirklich ein bisschen schneller besser
das klingt ein bisschen komisch
schneller besser sagt man das so kann
also sagen ja und
klar es gibt immer noch viele nazis gibt
immer noch viele leute die deutsche
ausgrenzen und sagen scheiß deutsche und
sowas finde ich alles sehr schade und
ich finde deutschland aufnehmen sollten
dennoch zusammenhalten weil wir in einem
land und wir sind deutschland real
sollten einfach zusammenhalten da sind
super schlusswort vielen dank
und wenn euch dieses video gefallen hat
dann gefällt euch auch sicherheit das
interview bzw das gespräch während der
eine talkshow mit den achsen die bei uns
erzählen warum sie party süchtig sind
und auch nicht von schlechten eltern
das als vor coca quasi ein kleines
interview mit white tea und gesang zu
ihrem fulminanten abschneiden bei einem
deutschen web video preis viel spaß und
ansonsten bis das programm